the Joe Rogan experience who's that big
right now who's that big of a star
there's so many stars now yeah I think
that's we've diluted the pool and
there's so many stars we've never heard
of it used to be like there was a star
we all knew about well we're old that's
part of there's people that someone I'm
like oh who's that person there for 70
million followers my god never heard of
what yeah what yeah we're out of the
loop um I'm Way more out of the loop
than you he's more in the loop than both
of us do you think that changes in a
couple weeks when they take the follower
accounts off of like there's only in
Australia it's hot they're testing it in
other countries before they drop it here
funny is that was there it's like [ __ ]
like they tried drugs out other
countries trying out the follower count
thing what that's gonna be weird I
wonder would how people gonna why are
they doing that because they feel like
they're doing a disservice to people by
having them compete yeah you you won't
be seeing other people's stuff so it
might sell a lot of people make money I
don't know not me I don't ever do ads on
Instagram but a lot of people do I don't
I bet you get offered to do ton of [ __ ]
a lot I say no because you just think
it's corny yeah I'll do ads for things I
like where I put it up for free yeah but
I've never seen you believe in yeah like
if like someone said oh it's [ __ ]
earth like maybe it is an ad but it's
not an ad I'm getting paid for like if I
find something that's cool you just do
it just put it up like this is a badass
I think thank you so much I think it
helps and I've been offered a lot of
money multiple times to do ads for
things on Instagram I'm like look I do
ads on my podcast everybody knows it's
an ad yeah if I'm doing I'm not doing
that on Instagram I'm just it doesn't
seem like it makes sense like if someone
goes to your Instagram they want to see
cool [ __ ] that you're interested in yeah
they want to see a picture of something
wanna see a picture of my dog or food or
[ __ ] sunset or a mountain or whatever
the [ __ ] it is they don't want to see
sneakers that your salad unless it's
like but if it's a friend of mine
sneakers that he's selling
I'll take a picture of that and put it
up but I don't want any money I think it
feels corny you know I think for you
especially I think people trust you so
much and you're known for telling the
truth and not selling out
if you had a hashtag ad what like it
just feels paid well it's like your
thing it would just be like make a good
product
yeah I do it for free all the time yeah
I really do and people I don't even know
if they have something cool I'll put it
up there have you ever felt like no
she's not worth it cuz you probably lose
in the long run yeah it's like if I was
poor yeah I would do it yeah if I was
poor I do it I did fear factor [ __ ] I'm
doing a lot of horse [ __ ] it's not I'm
not above whoring myself but I'm not
gonna [ __ ] myself if I have money yeah
that doesn't make any sense but that is
weird cuz I wonder how people are gonna
a lot of people make money from yeah
just delete I did not it's not related
directly to this but they deleted a
bunch of accounts apparently yesterday
accounts had had up to 13 million
followers really meme accounts and [ __ ]
weird the whole account for there were a
couple of reasons they might have done
it like well there's a lot of meme
accounts that steal jokes crazy make
money off of it there was a girl you saw
that girl on is a Meg right who was
calling out that a [ __ ] Jerry guy who
was just doing comics jokes it was out
his name was me I don't know Mike right
oh she's a comedy person yeah who big
comedy writer yeah and who was just like
connecting the comics joke to the meme
and so many that well at least they
slowed down like the progress of that
fat Jewish guy that slowed down he
doesn't have nearly the sort of
trajectory he used to have but that was
all what he was about this is like
taking people [ __ ] mm-hmm and
repurposing and making a lot of money
and then also like getting on television
shows being interviewed and not having a
[ __ ] talent at all just reposting
things and I people DM me all the time
he could night now that beveren scared
like can I use your tweet in my
Instagram feed now I have to do work to
say yes so you can approach you know
it's just like be a lot of people are
like curators I think they call it is
that why they deleted them for possibly
that article if there's like they could
have been taking advertising money and
not saying it I'm just putting an ad a
instagrams advertising deals
reposting people [ __ ] all they dead end
of articles said that there is no way
they can get those accounts back there's
non-negotiable oh [ __ ] well [ __ ] off but
so will it basically go everyone's gonna
have no followers you won't be able to
see that you'll be able to see your
account like you'll know every day I'm
gonna post an Instagram photo of my
account
yeah people are recognized [ __ ] I
mean people are [ __ ] falling off
cliffs taking selfies have you seen that
it's like the [ __ ] Darwin or you'll
still see the likes you just won't be
able to see your father
no no you'll be able to see how many
likes you have on your photos what I'll
do is I'll post something in the morning
and then three times throughout the day
I'll post it to see which how many likes
I got so everybody that's for sure gonna
happen
gangster moved it's gonna be so mad at
you you're [ __ ] by posse maybe showing
your like I'm mad your account yeah oh
that's the move posted on my Twitter
account posted on my Facebook cuz that's
a dumpster
[Applause]